oh
i remember so can we should we talk
about it sure yes it's not going to
happen again it's because we had such a
dry winter yes that's true
i remember but we could have could we
have what well if we get a good winter
then it could happen again sorry yeah it
could happen at some time it's not going
to happen this year no just when it was
guys were trying to scare me
and they were all standing and they were
hopping around they were everywhere
you mentioned to be crunchy
yeah accidentally yeah and sometimes
they'd land on your car yeah yeah okay
and then you oh yeah well he knew who
loved you know who loved the invasion
i'm telling you who got stopper invasion
birds because i saw a road runner with
literally four in its mouth and a beer
on the other hand
just so they just loved it but they're
not going to it's not going to happen
for a while that's funny do you okay
you're okay the hopper invasion it was
happy hour let's tell for that bird look
outside
grasshoppers no i'm just kidding i'm
kidding okay
there really was that that really was a
dad joke all right live look outside
right now a nice night i say that
because yesterday we had all that wind
today yes there'll be some elevated
breezes but nothing like we saw this
morning or early early morning those
winds were really blowing here's a high
for the day today 80 degrees okay that's
after 87 yesterday we knew today would
drop drop those temperatures 65 for the
low
and the record on the state 108. i can't
believe that back in 1947. currently
outside 74 for summerlin 76 for the
lakes new neighborhoods here to show you
81 downtown we're at 82 green valley 78
southern highlands and 81 for henderson
seven hills currently 79 includes anthem
as well if you're outside the valley
you're watching this thanks for watching
tonight indian spring 74 for you over
the hump prep you're at 79 and we're 86
all the way down in laughlin there's our
doppler network and we are picking up
look at this some snow showers way up in
utah and certainly into colorado this is
where we want it again right we want
that snow on the western part of the
rockies here because that feeds lake
powell and lake mead we're clear skies
right now and it should remain that way
tomorrow too the other good news is
tomorrow winds tomorrow won't be that
bad look at this a lot of our
neighborhoods less than 10 although we
could see them up to 10 to 15 some spots
that's still not as bad as we saw
earlier today wind forecast does show
those winds returning again on thursday
this is breezy
this is windy this is mom's day weekend
where we look think the strongest gusts
could be on mother's day where those
gusts could get up to 45 miles per hour
in some spots right so if you're making
outdoor plants make them indoors okay
because that wind will really be blowing
that day and we'll start to see it also
on monday morning as well so here's your
evening planner there's your wind speeds
a little breezy for early on in the
evening and then nine o'clock at night
75 degrees those winds decrease more
lighter winds also for eight news now at
11 we got 70 degrees and tomorrow
morning even calmer wind 67 at 8 a.m
lots of sunshine on tap for tomorrow
here's a look at your eight day forecast
you're eight on the eight where we're
really going to heat things up notice on
thursday and friday look at those
numbers getting close to triple digits
some neighborhoods will certainly reach
the century mark on friday if not
earlier cooler for the weekend look at
that dropping that almost more than 10
degrees from saturday sunday for mom's
day and then cooler 70s
that's below average next week but
unfortunately i just do not see any rain
in this eight day
that's your most accurate forecast guys
we'll send it